[Musique]
à la grande satisfaction des
associations de déportés et des
dirigeants de la communauté juive
jacques chirac s'est donc clairement
démarqué de son prédécesseur françois
mitterrand qui a toujours refusé de
présenter ses excuses au nom de la
république
françoise david des autobus parisiens
des fourgons de la police française
passionnant ce 16 juillet 1942 devant le
vélodrome d'hiver
ce matin là la plus grande salle de
sports de paris est devenue le centre de
détention des juges de la capitale
l'opération promise ou l'allemand est
baptisé vent printanier est menée par 4
550 policiers gendarmes et gardes
mobiles
elle prévoit l'arrestation de 28 mille
personnes 13 me en fait sont
effectivement raflé conduite ensemble au
vel d'hiv
les familles sont très vite séparé plus
de 4000 enfants seront regroupés à
pithiviers et beaune-la-rolande les
adultes son parc à drancy et dépouillée
de tous les convois vers auschwitz car
la solution finale
n'épargnant ni les uns ni les autres en
1993 pour la première fois une journée
nationale d'hommage aux victimes des
crimes de vichy est institué à
l'initiative de françois mitterrand
mais tout comme ses prédécesseurs il se
refuse à admettre la responsabilité
globale de l'état français pour lui
comme pour les autres chef de l'état le
régime de vichy est une parenthèse dans
l'histoire de la république
ubs n'a rien à voir j'estime avoir
conscience que la france n'ont pu n'est
pas responsable que ce sont des
minorités activistes qui ont saisi
l'occasion de la défaite pour s'emparer
du pouvoir et qui ont qu'ils sont
comptables de ces crimes là pas la
république pas la france la
reconnaissance aujourd'hui par jacques
chirac de la dette imprescriptible de la
france a été accueillie avec
satisfaction par la communauté juive
s'est également
condamné l'état français condamné vichy
explicitement exalté aussi l'idée d'une
france généreuse près de 80 me fit de
france ils revinrent jamais mais quand
la mort
[Musique]